una gran encuesta a nivel nacional
realizada recientemente mostró una tasa
de desempleo del 9 por ciento en eeuu
la alcaldesa de cierta ciudad desea
averiguar si estos resultados son
válidos para su ciudad por lo que decide
tomar una muestra entre los residentes
para verificar la tasa de desempleo en
su ciudad es significativamente
diferente al 9% se apeen la tasa de
desempleo en su ciudad por lo tanto las
siguientes son las hipótesis que
establecerán su hipótesis nula es que la
tasa de desempleo en su ciudad es
exactamente la misma que la de todo el
país y su hipótesis alternativa es que
no es la misma
bajo cuál de las siguientes condiciones
la alcaldesa estaría incurriendo en un
error del tipo 1 pausa el vídeo y ver si
puedes responder tú solo
bien hagámoslo juntos recordemos primero
lo que significa un error tipo 1 esto
ocurre cuando rechazamos una hipótesis
nula cuando esta hipótesis nula es
verdadera en general que hace que
cometas un error tipo 1 o un error tipo
2 estás haciendo algo equivocado algo
que no va de acuerdo a la realidad
aunque no sea tu intención en este caso
un error del tipo 1 sería rechazar la
hipótesis de que la tasa de desempleo es
del 9% en esta ciudad cuando de hecho si
es del 9% en esta ciudad así que veamos
cuál de las opciones corresponden la
primera dice ella concluye que la tasa
de desempleo en la ciudad no es del 9%
cuando en realidad si es en este caso
para concluir que la tasa de desempleo
no es del 9% tuvo que rechazar la
hipótesis nula a pesar de que la
hipótesis nula no es verdadera
es decir a pesar de que la tasa de
desempleo realmente es del 9% así que
vamos a marcar esta como nuestra opción
correcta esta es la opción correcta y
ahora vamos a leer las otras opciones
para asegurarnos de que en efecto sea la
respuesta ella concluye que la tasa de
desempleo en la ciudad no es del 9%
cuando en realidad no es bueno en este
caso no tenemos ningún tipo de error si
la hipótesis nula no es verdadera no hay
problema de rechazarla así que esto no
sería un error ella concluye que la tasa
de desempleo en la ciudad es del 9%
cuando en realidad si es de nueva cuenta
esto no sería un error
esto sería no rechazar la hipótesis
nuland
cuando la hipótesis nula es de hecho
verdadera eso no es un error y la opción
de dicen ella concluye que la tasa de
desempleo en la ciudad es del 9% cuando
en realidad no
en este caso ella no está rechazando una
hipótesis nula que en realidad es falsa
así que esta opción también es un error
pero es un error de tipo 2 déjame
notarlo así que la manera de abordar
esto es primero detectar si estás
cometiendo un error es decir estoy
rechazando algo que es verdadero o no
estoy rechazando algo que es falso y
cuando rechazamos algo que es verdadero
vamos a decir que el error es tipo 1
cuando no rechazamos algo que es falso
decimos que es error tipo 2 bien con
esto en mente hagamos otro ejemplo
en una universidad les interesa
averiguar si deben construir otra
cafetería para esto se decide realizar
una encuesta a una muestra de
estudiantes con el objetivo de verificar
si hay evidencia contundente de que la
proporción de estudiantes interesados en
consumir en la cafetería es mayor que el
40% en dado caso se considerarán
construir una nueva cafetería sea pep la
proporción de estudiantes interesados en
consumir en la cafetería estas son las
hipótesis planteadas y bueno observan la
hipótesis nula es que 40 por ciento o
menos de los estudiantes están
interesados en consumir en la cafetería
mientras que la hipótesis alternativa es
que más del 40 por ciento de los
estudiantes sí lo están
cuáles son las simplificaciones de un
error tipo 2 en este caso de nueva
cuenta pausa el vídeo y pese puedes
obtener la solución
mismo bien hagámoslo juntos recordemos
en qué consiste el error tipo 2 acabamos
de mencionar lo consiste en no rechazar
una hipótesis nula a pesar de que es
falsa
esto quiere decir que esto es falso lo
que significa que más del 40% de los
estudiantes si están interesados en
consumir en la cafetería pero si no
rechazamos la hipótesis nula lo que va a
suceder será que no se va a construir
una nueva cafetería pues habremos
concluido que no hay una cantidad
suficiente de estudiantes que la usaría
aunque en realidad si hay bastantes
estudiantes interesados y la antigua
cafetería no se va a dar abasto la
primera opción es no se considera
construir una nueva cafetería a pesar de
que se requiere otra vez esta es la
respuesta adecuada es justo lo que
estábamos diciendo veamos las demás no
se considera construir una nueva
cafetería pues no se requiere bueno esta
es una conclusión correcta se considera
construir una nueva cafetería a pesar de
que no se requiere este es el caso en el
que se rechaza la hipótesis nula a pesar
de que esta es verdadera es decir esta
opción lo que nos indica es l
déjame ponerlo ya que si consideran
construir una nueva cafetería está en
rechazar la hipótesis nula a pesar de
que no se requiere es decir a pesar de
que la hipótesis nula es verdadera así
que en este caso sería un error de tipo
1 se considera construir una cafetería
pues así se requiere en este caso no hay
error esta sería una conclusión adecuada
por lo tanto esta y ésta son
conclusiones adecuadas
son los resultados de errores tipo 2 y
tipo 1 respectivamente nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo